the prophet Muhammad s. wasallam told us
whoever builds a mosque for Allah Allah
will build for him a similar house in
jenah and we know the great reward that
will not only be gained but rather will
fill your grave after your death
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives shahada in the Masid
whenever someone learns something in the
Masid yes that will be something that
you will have on your scale
[Music]
how are you guys doing and
congratulations and congratulations to
all the Muslims in the world who are
supplicating and asking Allah that this
tyrannical man Bashar ALB and Bashar the
dog the butcher the murderers the
murderous man the Tyrant the desper the
Barb the Barbarian the Barbarian half a
you're talking about the people that are
going to be happy it's going to be the
families of the half a million that have
been killed under murdered under his
regime unbelievable really and do you
know what's the irony of this is that he
through his actions people were
relegated to being immigrants all over
the world and now he is an immigrant
himself he and his family scared along
in a hurry I may add to Russia uh and so
he's an immigrant illegal immigrant from
president to illegal in many ways you
You could argue that is a more painful
punishment than death itself having to
see people in his own country tear down
pictures of him tear down statues of him
it's absolute humiliation at his
Pinnacle
however we need we needed some good news
with what's going on in Palestine and
around the world did this was the good
news that the umah required and
alhamdulillah it's a breath of fresh air
a lot of people are returning back to
their homes a lot of people are going
back and you see the amount the the
joyous scenes that are emerging from
Syria are all over social media people
are genuinely happy and it's not just
coming from mainstream media it's coming
from independent people that have filmed
and uploaded so it's not something
that's orchestrated it's it's a
genuine uh what do you call it
atmosphere festive mood yeah yeah
totally vibrant throughout the country
from all the way up to dsh Damascus uh
all the way up to from aleo all the way
down to to Damascus and the whole
country we're seeing this festive
atmosphere that you're talking about but
one thing that I really wanted to talk
about because it has become an area of
controversy now especially some
Palestinian prop Palestinian activists
are these kind of left leaning um not
left leaning in the social sense but
more in the geopolitical sense that you
know they've got these unusual ties with
anything to do with Pro Russia or
anything to do with Pro Iran to the
point where they would turn a blind eyee
to the suffering that you just described
at the top of the beginning of this
video um I find it quite despicable
actually that they think that the be all
and end all is the Palestinian issue we
don't sacrifice one tragic issue for
another we condemn them all and if you
want to see I mean and I think this is
probably topical and pertinent at this
point some evidence what better evidence
to show of the torture and the barbarism
of this man
Bashar thenna prison which is um one of
the most brutal prisons we saw kids
there I even saw a person inside the
prison I saw a child we'll see in the
video now but we saw one person inside
like they put like a camera inside the
cell and the guy was just dead inside
the cell or was a woman I don't even
know was a man or was a corpse it's
essentially an extermination camp so you
can't be protesting on the one side on
the one hand for the release of
Palestinian prisoners in the West Bank
and on the other hand turn a blind eye
to the Syrian prisoners in inside a
prison or anywhere else let's take a
look at how the people when they were
released from prison reacted let's take
a look at
[Music]
that fore
Al
so we're seeing there women you see a
child there somehow and they've being
released from the prison what do you
make of these scenes Sean I think when
you see stuff like that and so many
independent filmmakers people on the
ground that have uploaded their stuff
and on the other hand when you hear ah
they've just made it easier for Israel
to take over they've just made it easier
for this or that's what we're hearing
now that's what I'm seeing and that's
that's the political based argument and
that's divorcing the reality of the
ground which is okay you want to
maintain a a specific political identity
there countering the Western narrative
and that's fine but don't do it at the
expense of the Muslims you know what I
mean and you're saying no but it's
conspiracy I'm sorry but there's so much
evidence that's that's come out from
different perspectives and from
different mediums that clearly talks
about the barbarism of this man that
they call Bashar you're absolutely right
and look I mean they they're making this
oh well this group these groups are
proscribed terrorist organizations and
they're linked to such and such no one's
saying anything I don't think I have you
have or anyone else has said anything
about or any other group what we are
celebrating is the downfall of a man
called Bashar alassad who has done this
to his population we are waiting and
seeing what's happening just like the
British government is waiting to see
what's happening with this group any
other group we are hoping for stability
we pray for stability we're hoping that
uh the these people in Syria can be
strong enough to deter any attacks from
the belligerent and transgressive
Israeli State and I think I mean let's
be honest they're saying well B this
breaks down the axis of resistance I saw
some of the the analyses and stuff like
breaks down because of the you knowah
was being uh you know the the passage of
supplies was through Syria from Iran
tobah breaks down the so-called access
the Golden Heights yeah and the Golden
Heights now the buff zone is been thing
but the point is is that first of all
what axis of resistance are we talking
about when number one Iran has let's be
call a spade a spade what what damage is
it actually done to the state of Israel
what damage number two Syria has done
zero damage what you can speculate all
you like about what these new groups in
Coalition or in a Unity or um solit in
in by themselves or together we'll do in
the next six months or one year how
they'll react to Israel but we can for
sure say Bashar alassad has already done
nothing to Israel nothing at all he's
not done nothing about the Golden
Heights you've got occupied territory in
his own land he's done nothing at all so
don't act as if Bashar Al Assad was this
big thorn in the side of Israel I'm
sorry to say
mostly people who are saying this with
real Vigor and making this point really
strongly I suspect are actually being
either funded by Russia okay funded by
them or they um you know are just loyal
to Russia and or Iran this is nonsense I
mean at the end of the day if you're
saying Bashar Al Assad is in this in
this position and he's the The Thorn on
the side of the of the Israelis and he's
he's not even no one missile one has
come out of of Syria nonsense sorry to
say not one missile has come out of that
place as many missiles has come out of
Syria as any other Arab state which is
zero so don't pretend he was this big
thorn of the side and heah they were
funding Hezbollah yes but what were heah
doing they were taking over lands in
Syria which is occupation and of itself
they they're not welcome there they were
funding to do occupation actually what
what's what
Iranian uh proxies and militias and
Russian NE base is doing in in
Syria why is that a good thing for Syria
do you think we just want to be devoured
and colonized and occupied so are we
just trading off one kind of occupation
for another so sorry to say these are
all flat uh flatly false assertions that
this is like you know a Thor in the side
of the axis of resistance and I'm not
convinced are you convinced by this
argument not at all and the thing is
when you're talking all this political
jargon but then you're sacrificing our
Muslims saying no no no that's it's just
a lie and it's just a conspiracy and
this and that how do you disprove such
objective evidence of the persecution of
Muslims that like I said have numbered
up to half a half a million yeah half a
million we're talking chemical weapons
we're talking about torture we're
talking about all sorts of kuy
ideologies yeah we saw we saw the videos
and saying like you know who is your
Lord this you're not going to Gaslight
us we've spoken to too many people
firsthand who are from Syria that came
from Syria and told us what's going on
and with that we will
conclude the prophet Muhammad s wasam
told us that when the son of Adam dies
all of his Good Deeds are interrupted
they are finished except for three
things a continuous charity and a
beneficial knowledge and also a a
righteous offspring that makes Dua for
him your brothers and sisters in Islam
net from Norway are establishing a Masid
a DA Center and fulfilling a great
portion of this Hadith on your behalf
establishing a Masid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do whenever someone
prays there whenever someone gives
shahada in the Masid whenever someone
learns something in the Masid yes that
will be something that you will have on
your scale so give generously and Allah
will give you even more oh